[Música]
este 6 de marzo se cumple un mes desde
los dos terremotos más letales que han
padecido Turquía y Siria en su época
moderna los sismos de magnitudes de 7,8
y de 7,5 fueron los primeros y luego
vinieron más de 11.000 réplicas según la
autoridad turca para el manejo de
desastres y emergencia todo esto ha
dejado más de 53.000 personas muertas y
más de un millón de personas sin hogar
ahora el gran reto es la reconstrucción
pero no es nada fácil en ninguno de los
dos países Pues en Siria los terremotos
golpearon especialmente las áreas
controladas por los Rebeldes en Turquía
el desastre llegó el mismo año de
elecciones parlamentarias y
presidenciales con las que el mandatario
reyecta iberdán Busca empezar su tercera
década en el poder antes de comenzar el
análisis veamos un repaso de qué ha
sucedido en los últimos 30 días
un mes después aún no se ha sentado la
polvadera del terremoto de magnitud 7.8
que sacudió Turquía y Siria
seguimos retirando escombros aquí
retiramos entre 200 y 250 toneladas de
escombros aquí cada día
en cereal Banco Mundial estima los daños
en 5,100 millones de dólares más de
50.000 personas perdieron la vida y para
los que quedan se trata de una
emergencia humanitaria en Siria la ayuda
tardó en llegar a Los afectados en las
zonas del noroeste controladas por los
Rebeldes decenas de miles de personas
siguen desaparecidas y cientos de miles
perdieron sus hogares sumándose a los
muchos más serios desplazados por 12
años de guerra en el país
incluso antes del terremoto las
necesidades aumentaban mientras que la
ayuda internacional disminuía pero no
debemos cerrar los ojos ni dar la
espalda al pueblo sirio no podemos
permitir que esta sea una crisis
olvidada
en Turquía la indignación ha aumentado
por la lentitud de la respuesta del
gobierno algunos han descrito Cómo
intentaban sacar a las víctimas con sus
propias manos mientras esperaban la
llegada de los equipos de rescate
mientras se prepara para luchar en las
elecciones de mayo el presidente arduan
ha pedido Perdón
[Música]
debido al efecto devastador de los
temblores a las difíciles condiciones
meteorológicas y a los daños en las
infraestructuras no hemos podido
trabajar con la eficacia deseadan les
pido perdón por ello
Mientras tanto más de 200 personas han
sido detenidas en Turquía por mantener
unas normas de construcción deficientes
que están poniendo aún más vidas en
peligro ante las múltiples réplicas
para analizar el impacto que han dejado
estos terremotos invitamos a talia iscan
especialista turca en seguridad y
política internacional y quien está en
Ciudad de México también nos acompaña
kibank ulusoy profesor de relaciones
internacionales en istanbul University y
quien nació en alejandreta una de las
zonas más afectadas y a ustedes nuestros
televidentes le recordamos que también
hacen parte de este debate dejen sus
comentarios y todas las preguntas que
tengan a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter Facebook e Instagram
como arroba franz24 raya al piso es y
pueden comentar con la etiqueta numeral
el debate f24 a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como arroba María cl Aguirre no
olviden que todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa están disponibles en
Apple podcast Spotify deezer y TuneIn
comenzamos entonces en nuestro debate
sobre los terremotos en Turquía y para
eso quiero darle primero la bienvenida a
Thalia iscan Gracias por estar con
nosotros y Comencemos por hablar de Cuál
ha sido la respuesta del gobierno de
revierta iberdroan a este desastre
Muy buenas tardes María Antes que nada
Muchísimas gracias por el foro pues tal
como hemos visto en breve video que
ustedes prepararon ya vimos la respuesta
de la jeeptide Perdón no la primera
respuesta fue cuando Sí el gobierno
aceptó que a lo mejor no pudo manejar
los tiempos de la manera más pragmática
y de la manera más eficaz y posterior a
eso ahorita la política actual ha sido
enfocar enfocarse 100% al tema de
reconstrucción y reparación Mira estamos
hablando más de de más de cuarenta y
seis mil muertos en la zona Y todavía se
sospecha que pueden encontrarse más
cuerpos y estamos hablando de más de
diez ciudades impactadas en términos de
infraestructura en términos de seguridad
en términos de de seguridad ambiental
seguridad humana financiera y en muchos
términos no entonces aquí más la
respuesta del gobierno creo que Turquía
también ha recibido una respuesta muy
fuerte por parte de la comunidad
internacional Mira yo desde acá te puedo
decir que México fue el primer país
latinoamericano que que mandó un gran
Equipo de rescate Y sí obtuvieron
resultados bastante pragmáticos muchos
países estaban allá en el campo no
incluyo azerbaiyán Rusia la Unión
Europea Malasia México muchos
involucrantes más que se cooperaron pero
pues es un desastre bastante grave es un
catástrofe que esta región no estaba
100% preparado al parecer y también
tomando en consideración los factores
políticos pues hay que recalcar que
estamos hablando de una de las regiones
más vulnerables en términos geopolíticos
porque es la frontera justo con el
conflicto de Siria y también es una
frontera que donde en donde Turquía está
batallando con diferentes grupos
terroristas desde hace muchos años
entonces pues no estamos hablando de un
territorio muy desarrollado en términos
de la seguridad humana y encima de ese
ese catástrofe claramente desestabilizó
el país y yo creo que ahorita el
gobierno Turco también está
experimentando nuevas metodologías justo
para reconstruir estas ciudades y
asegurarse de que al menos las personas
que sobrevivieron tengan una vida
decente que tengan techo que tengan
alimentos talia y como usted lo dice
estos terremotos golpearon especialmente
en 11 provincias que son la más las más
pobres de toda Turquía y de hecho Allí
es donde vive el 50% de los migrantes
sirios en territorio Turco Le quiero
preguntar entonces aquí ulusoy qué tan
difícil ha sido llevar la ayuda
humanitaria a estas regiones y uniendo
con lo que decía Natalia cómo ha
respondido el gobierno Turco frente a
estas ayudas internacionales que ha
obtenido
bueno primero creo que tengo que
corregir una cosa
esta región no es una región tan
subdesarrollada es una región que
incluye once provincias
puedo decir que la tercera zona más
desarrollada de de Turquía después de
Estambul y la zona de Bárbara y Mirna y
la zona de cemida Y esa
bueno
las provincias como hatay como adana
como gaseante como
las provincias
bastante desarrolladas comparando con el
norte y este este de Turquía Así que
Aquí
el problema ha sido desde el principio
la incapacidad estatal de responder en
tiempo
y como el presidente de ruán también
aceptó y bueno como ustedes han dicho
ha pedido Perdón del pueblo
que daba un voto
sostenido desde los años
2000 dos Cuando él vino al poder como el
Primer Ministro en Turquía Así que es la
zona bastante desarrollada en muchos
términos comparando con el resto del
país y es ladrona donde el gobierno
tiene un apoyo
sostenible
en los últimos dos décadas del partido
que gobierno el país ahora
la otra cosa que podría responder es
también me parece un poco sorprendente
es sorprendente porque como usted ha
dicho Turquía
está alojando como decir como podemos
decir o está
esa ha recibido después de la guerra
civil en Siria
más o menos cuatro millones de
refugiados y
Y entonces ha podido demostrar con
capacidad Estatal bastante fuerte
absorber y relaja
como decir real alojar tanta gente
con
centros de resfriados en diferentes
partes del
país incluyó que que incluye este
provincias que están en la frontera
hacia Siria como Antioquia como como
gaseante como quiles son
fronteras son provincias de la frontera
así es Siria Así que lo que me parece
sorprendente Cómo o qué Turquía ya ha
podido este poder Estatal
de responder a un crisis tan fuerte en
Siria no ha podido responder a un crisis
muy similar bueno viene del terremoto
Pero como ustedes han visto los imágenes
ha sido como un como un guerra civil o
como un bombardeo de esas provincias
como usted Nosotros hemos visto en raja
en las provincias de Siria así es Es
algo complicado
[Música]
Déjeme lo interrumpo porque quiero
hacerle la siguiente pregunta y es usted
habla y enfatiza en la dificultad que ha
tenido el gobierno para responder a este
desastre sabiendo que ha tenido la
fortaleza para responder por ejemplo a
la migración de los sirios a esta
migración forzada Le quiero preguntar
concretamente sobre el impuesto al
terremoto y es que en 1999 Turquía tuvo
también un terremoto devastador que dejó
más de 17.000 muertos y después de este
sismo se creó algo llamado el impuesto
al terremoto que iba a ser provisional y
luego perduró a lo largo del tiempo y el
propósito de este dinero recaudado era
prevenir futuros terremotos ya que
Turquía se encuentra en entre sobre tres
placas tectónicas diferentes Entonces
era previsible que los terremotos
volvieran a ocurrir Qué pasó con ese
dinero de esos impuestos
sí uno de los ministros de ese gobierno
hace tiempo lo explicó diciendo que lo
habían gastado para otras
y eso fue un un un un como decir una
frase muy
muy desafortunada desafortunado Y eso es
lo que este hemos visto
especialmente en esas diez provincias
bueno el impuesto para el terremoto
también
[Música]
estaba bastante alto porque
porque esas provincias no son provincias
tan pobres lo que estas estáis viendo
ahora en esas imágenes por ejemplo fue
por lo
fue el resultado de de la economía de
construcción
o la economía
del desarrollo basado sobre la
construcción en los últimos más o menos
20 años y esas muchas de esas provincias
[Música]
han crecido tanto han crecido tan
fuertemente y han expandido Tan tanto
hacia las zonas y que no tienen un un
digamos un fuerte
terreno
y
podría decir
que algunos de las pequeñas ciudades que
pertenecen a esas provincias han crecido
desde Diez mil hacia cien mil desde Diez
mil Así es de 150 quiere decir el
crecimiento de población
y la economía de construcción
ha preparado
por lo que he visto esa desastre y ha
sido un crecimiento exponencial como
usted lo dice en una economía basada en
la construcción pero Hay un pero enorme
Y es que después de los terremotos de
1939 y de 1999 había un código para
construir con técnicas de sismo
resistencia Le quiero preguntar a tal Y
entonces porque los opositores han
criticado al gobierno de erdoan y lo han
señalado de otorgarle licencias a sus
socios que No necesariamente cumplían
con los requisitos para construir estas
viviendas qué tan cierto es esto y por
qué el desastre fue tan profundo como lo
vimos con casas destruidas totalmente
creo que es una pregunta bastante
interesante y compleja pero nada más
deja también retomar una parte que que
mi colega que el profesor ha mencionado
pues hablando en términos de desarrollo
y vulnerabilidad incluso aquí reitero de
acuerdo a los datos de 2017 de
organización Estatal de planificación de
Turquía hatay ocupa el número 31 como
ciudad malatia ocupa 42 Entonces sí
entiendo que no lo podemos categorizar
explícitamente como las ciudades más
pobres pero sí este nivel de desarrollo
socioeconómico explícitamente muestra
una vulnerabilidad a la comparación de
las zonas metropolitanas de acuerdo a
nuestras instituciones de datos
tangibles y respecto a lo que tú tú me
estás comentando yo creo que allá hubo
un factor muy importante el factor de
impredecibilidad entonces claramente ese
catástrofe se politizó y claramente la
opinión pública se valora muchísimo y
más en esas fechas donde estamos
hablando este de una posible renovación
o otras elecciones un periodo de
elecciones pues claramente la opinión
pública
va a poner su sus reacciones sobre la
mesa Al momento de votar porque pues
Turquía final le cuenta es un es un país
democrático Entonces allá vamos a ver
qué qué se refleja por parte del pueblo
el factor de impredecibilidad claramente
fue un un elemento donde el estado
nación falló y es por eso que incluso el
presidente de la república reconoció su
error y ahorita están todos todos esos
polémicas este políticos Sin embargo a
mí me gustaría recalcar un punto o sea
en cuestiones catastróficos y políticos
y más en un país geopolíticamente tan
clave como Turquía incluso veinticuatro
horas pueden cambiar muchas cosas y una
de las razones esta crisis política fue
esto primer día en primeros veinticuatro
días que se hizo en la primera semana
que se hizo porque Turquía claramente
cuenta con con una capacidad amplia de
científicos Pero entonces allá la
participación de los ongs relevantes y
la participación del gobierno yo creo
que haya había muchos factores de de de
no comunicación Al momento de ayudar o a
la mejor el tema de tomar precauciones
no yo creo que es difícil decir cien por
ciento de que todo fue posible de evitar
pero claramente Aquí vemos como el
estado nación ha fallado en ciertos
temas y ahorita Nos está dejando claro
el pueblo de que según van a tomar las
medidas y pues primero antes que nada es
la recuperación de estas ciudades porque
también hay ciertas amenazas desde la
perspectiva de seguridad si todavía no
podemos recuperar estas ciudades si
todavía se encuentran allá más cuerpos
eso incluso representa una amenaza y un
riesgo de una posible epidemia en región
Entonces allá Es cuando vamos a estar
viendo
múltiples problemas de seguridad que van
a empezar que pueden llegar a impactar a
la región y pueden ampliar Sí y llegar a
todo el país en ese contexto entonces
respecto al tema político yo creo que
muy pronto vamos a ver los resultados de
de cómo cómo refleja la opinión pública
en en esos procesos democráticos y por
otro lado el problema Todavía no se
acaba todavía necesitamos atención
humanitaria claro y sí Le quiero
preguntar y es esos resultados todavía
no se han visto como usted bien lo dijo
pues se verán totalmente en las
elecciones presidenciales y
parlamentarias que tanto le cobran a
erdoanía y a su partido el akp esto lo
que usted llama la falla del Estado
nación sin embargo hay encuestas que
muestran que no ha sido del todo
afectado Y es que por ejemplo la
encuestadora metropol sacó unos
resultados en noviembre antes del
terremoto en los que decía que el 50,7%
de las personas no votarían por una
reelección de erdoan y tiene un apoyo
del 43% tenía un apoyo del 43% Aunque
tanto este partido de la Cape como el
partido movimiento nacionalista con el
que haría Alianza los dos barrerían en
las elecciones parlamentarias y metropol
sacó unas encuestas ante la agencia
reuters este mismo mes en marzo y dijo
que los porcentajes Se mantenían casi
iguales Le quiero preguntar aquí van muy
muy brevemente porque cree que estas
porcentajes de popularidad siguen siendo
casi los mismos después del terremoto
después del terremoto
bueno es que es eso no estoy seguro
el descuento terremoto Perdona perdido
un poquito poder
eso se ve muy claramente pero
los partidos de oposición han tenido un
crisis entre ellos hace más o menos tres
cuatro días o una semana digamos
que
hay un hay una debilidad
de la oposición en general
en términos de discurso en términos de
comunicación entre ellos y tal
Esperamos que
que se se corrija eso también pero
justo antes del del terremoto la
popularidad de erdoan estaba bastante
sosten
gracias a algunos digamos algunos
algunos
políticas
económicas especialmente
resolventos resolviendo resolviendo el
problema de pensiones también
Bueno una una política
populista que
ayudan
mantener un poder
Bueno más que
35% por sí mismo pero
estoy pensando que su poder está
no está en manos seguros
de cómo digamos hace tiempo sí como
usted lo dice quizás no tenga Tanto
poder y popularidad como lo tenía antes
Le quiero preguntar a Thalia si ella
opina lo mismo y si es así entonces
porque el presidente erdogan decidió
insistir en que las elecciones generales
sean el 14 de mayo y no Julio como lo
había dicho anteriormente o incluso 2024
como en algún momento lo pensó
tal como se plantea el escenario es
bastante complejo y estamos hablando de
ciertas encuestas pero acuérdate que
estos datos son cambiantes para nosotros
aquí poder hablar de un porcentaje o de
una decadencia en términos de ciencias
sociales así metodológicamente Creo que
necesitamos más datos de las
instituciones bien respaldados Y ahorita
que Turquía dado que Turquía está en una
crisis humanitaria pues va a ser difícil
volver a hacer estos cincuenta encuestas
Entonces yo la verdad es que sí tengo
una una visión bastante escéptica hacia
estas encuestas porque creo que es el
tiempo de priorizar la agenda de la
ayuda humanitaria no tanto las
posibilidades porque hay mucho factor de
imprevisibilidad Incluso en estas
encuestas claramente los partidos que
están en contra han tenido diferentes
discursos han tenido mucha impotencia
ante la situación pero eso tampoco nos
asegura cien por de que el régimen
ha estado de decadencia porque también
aparte es un partido que sí ha tenido
una influencia muy fuerte en diferentes
segmentos de la población Entonces
cuando hablamos de eso yo creo que hay
que dividirlo no como hablamos de de las
zonas más metropolitanas hablamos de las
zonas Rurales y pues los datos que tú me
estás diciendo son sorprendentes pueden
cambiarse y más en esos momentos de
crisis
tampoco podemos nosotros prever que que
va a ser la política exacta de AC party
para volver a acercarse a la población o
para poder recuperar estas heridas de la
población que es un dolor nacional No
únicamente de un partido sí resultados
entonces imposibles de prevenir como
usted lo dice Ahora quiero que hablemos
de la oposición Porque tanto usted como
coinciden en que la oposición está
afectada recordemos que en diciembre de
2022 fue condenado a dos años de prisión
el alcalde de Estambul
y que era uno quizás de las caras más
visibles de la oposición y que le podría
hacer contrapeso en unas eventuales
presidenciales a erdoan y ya la
oposición no tiene ninguna cara visible
por un lado y segundo no tiene un plan
no ha presentado un plan para
reconstruir el país después de los
terremotos qué tan dividida está la
oposición Le quiero preguntar aquí muy
brevemente
la oposición ha podido mantener
desde hace un año y medio
mantener y establecer y mantener
[Música]
una una línea
bueno bastante fuerte comparando con
con otros tiempos
de la política turca
y un partido de seis partidos están en
están sentados en una mesa redonda han
reunido
13 veces
y ahora han demostrado el candidato de
la oposición
el candidato presidencial el jefe del
partido de la oposición principal que
es partido republicano
acaban acaban de anunciar que
ya tienen un candidato concreto eso fue
bueno de uno de los más visibles
debilidades de la oposición desde hace
mucho tiempo no han podido
elegir un candidato concreto de seis
partidos y los otros también
pero
si me permite un minuto y que haría
Añadir otra cosa acabo de
comprender
entender digamos
lo que están intentando hacer
ahora por lo que he entendido están
intentando construir una estrategia
cambiar el régimen
quiero decir el régimen que se
estableció a partir de
la
del golpe militar en 1980 desde hace
mucho tiempo no habían mencionado esa
cosa pero que estoy intentando
comprender lo que quieran hacer ahora sí
el problema es no es la la caída de Don
es la caída del régimen que se
estableció en los años 80 y ante esto
que se enfrentarán en las elecciones que
es por un lado construir un nuevo
régimen y cambiar al actual que es lo
que plantea la oposición según usted nos
cuenta o dos reconstruir juntos el país
que es la bandera con la que erdoan está
promoviendo se Asimismo y a sus partidos
aliados en estas elecciones Le quiero
preguntar a Thalia en medio de estas
posturas internas En qué papel queda
entonces Turquía en un mapa más
internacional
Empezando por su posición como mediador
en la guerra entre Rusia y Ucrania
creo que es una pregunta muy interesante
María porque pues Turquía de este de
este los mediados del año pasado ha
tenido un papel muy impactante en el
contexto de la guerra ruso ucraniana no
fue el primer país mediador que sí pudo
proponer una estrategia tangible y estoy
hablando del acuerdo de granos pero
ahorita qué pasa pues mira lo que yo te
puedo decir de este mi cosmovisión que
tampoco pues representa un hecho
histórico político pues claramente
Turquía ahorita posterior haber vivido
un catástrofe así
se puede y se va a llegar a priorizar
este problema de reconstrucción sea
régimen o sea reconstrucción de un nuevo
concepto de seguridad Estatal o de
presencia Estatal independientemente de
Qué partido se ahorita todos tienen que
estar reunidos para pensar en un futuro
sostenible del país ante antes que el de
politización que también has mencionado
entonces hay contratiempos y por otro
lado yo creo que orgánicamente cuando tú
pones sobremesa un nuevo prioridad que
sale a partir de un momento de crisis
tus otras tareas pueden automáticamente
caerse en un en un deckrand político eso
no quiere decir que Turquía saldría de
de ese escenario de ser una potencia
influyente en el tema de las relaciones
internacionales y Relaciones Exteriores
en la región Pero yo creo que sí a
Turquía ahorita se le espera tiempos
complejos difíciles de reconstrucción y
orgánicamente por ser un estado nación
va a enfocarse O sea yo pienso que se va
a enfocar más en su agenda interno y
posteriormente en algún momento Espero
que pudiera tomar ese gran papel que
tuvo como un país Pacífico mediador
objetivo ante este gran conflicto que
nos desestabilizó a a nivel global Claro
pero por otro lado no solo ha sido
mediador sino por ejemplo en guerras
como la de Siria ha participado
activamente Le quiero preguntar a vivank
Cómo mantener este futuro sostenible de
Turquía como lo mencionaba Thalia en
medio uno de la guerra en Siria y dos de
su avance comercial en continentes como
África
bueno desafortunadamente y que tengo que
confesar
que el terremoto ha sido un golpe
físico y psicológico para la política
exterior
ha sido
bueno ha afectado muy seriamente el
moral de los políticos que estaba
bastante alto en los últimos
años
bueno
como Italia ha mencionado
dan vuelto dentro del país para bueno
para resolver por intentar resolver
cuestiones muy serias económicas y
y los problemas que ha causado por ese
terremoto en diez once provincias y
y yo veo muy difícil que Turquía podría
podría contener a esa política exterior
tan activa tan provocante y también tan
intervencionista en muchos centros
perfecto
panorama de cómo los terremotos afectan
la política exterior de Turquía
germinar Le quiero preguntar y le quiero
pedir que haga una conclusión de Cómo
cree que afecta la política interna
teniendo en cuenta las elecciones de
mayo
eso es una pregunta para mí sí señor
para usted
vamos a ver un
acaba de anunciar que
quieran hacer las elecciones en
en medios de mayo de ese año quiere
decir que tenemos más o menos tres meses
y esos tres meses van a ser muy
difíciles
y
quiere sostener su poder
con unas políticas económicas que que
para
digamos cubrir
sitio muy seria muy serios defectos
económicos en la zona del terremoto y en
el resto del país cuál sería
su conclusión de cómo estos terremotos
han afectado la política interna turca
pues mi conclusión podría ser lo
siguiente pues es un catástrofe que ha
impactado No únicamente a Turquía sino
también un país vecino que se encuentra
en un conflicto actualmente y estoy
hablando de Siria entonces creo que es
un es un gran reto No únicamente para el
gobierno sino también para otros actores
relevantes participantes en el escenario
tal como los ongs a nivel nacional
internacional
la sociedad civil turca los países
externos que tienen que mantienen
relación diplomática fuerte con Turquía
y también pues claramente el gobierno y
todos los partidos participantes es un
reto pero yo otra vez Quiero llamar la
atención de que es una crisis
humanitaria y es una crisis de seguridad
nacional que ha generado impacto también
a nivel regional sí me escuchan sí
perfectamente
Entonces yo creo que sí es son tiempos
muy difíciles porque ahorita está en
luto todavía Yo creo que la cancillería
turca sí ha sacado un buen trabajo
porque todas esas organizaciones de
cooperación internacional tuvieron éxito
al menos aquí en México la Embajada de
Turquía en México sí pudo recopilar
muchísima ayuda también gracias a la
población mexicana pero estamos nada más
en el inicio de ese camino de
reconstrucción desde una perspectiva de
seguridad humana entonces son tiempos
muy difíciles es difícil predecir algo
un escenario político y Esperamos que
cual cualquier cambio que sea que
represente el interés
democrático del pueblo Turco talia
Gracias por esto y usted tal como lo
menciona estos terremotos por supuesto
también han afectado a Siria y a toda
nuestra audiencia les recuerdo que aquí
en el debate Ya hicimos un programa
previo precisamente sobre las
afectaciones que dejaron los terremotos
en ese país en medio de casi 12 años de
guerra daría gracias por estar con
nosotros
muchísimas gracias y también le
agradezco a Iván por su tiempo aquí en
el debate gracias muchas gracias a todos
ustedes Gracias por sintonizarnos en
nombre de nuestro equipo técnico Les
agradecemos por estar aquí con nosotros
la producción de este programa estuvo a
cargo de Laura garzón y Luis Montes y la
producción de invitados a cargo de Tania
Herrera ustedes sigan con Franz 24
[Música]